but let's jump into that first major
story here it is
from eyewitness abc 7 the latest update
fbi seizes electronics from rudy
giuliani's manhattan apartment
they say federal agents carried out a
search warrant at the home and office
of former new york city mayor rudy
giuliani wednesday morning sources
familiar with the matter confirmed abc
news
sources tell abc news electronic devices
including giuliani's cell phone
were confiscated by authorities a
spokesperson
and attorney for giuliani have not
responded to abc news wednesday
afternoon giuliani's son
andrew who was mulling a run for new
york governor spoke
briefly outside his father's apartment
quote any american red or blue should be
extremely disturbed by what happened
here today
this is disgusting this is absolutely
absurd and it's the continued
politicization
of the justice department that we have
seen and it has to stop
if this can happen to the former
president's lawyer this can happen to
any american
they say the warrants were in relation
to the justice department's
investigation into the business dealings
of former president donald trump's
personal lawyer
notably according to the new york times
it was a far a violation so was he
acting as a forward agent lobbying on
behalf of ukrainians
to donald trump or was this
retaliation not only are they going
after rudy giuliani but according to
wall street journal they are trying to
find communications between giuliani and
journalist john solomon you may recall
the previous controversy when i think it
was adam schiff right who was spying on
an american journalist
because he didn't like the information
that was being published and i guess he
actually published private information
from solomon it's been a while since
we've covered that story
but my friends uh what what do you say i
don't know banana republic
are we are we there is it happened
already there was a time
in my lifetime where if the fbi and the
doj
served a warrant and they confiscated a
bunch of documents and equipment and
stuff my first instinct would have been
they probably have a good reason to do
that
today my instinct is they just trying to
get everybody that had anything to do
with donald j
trump period because we see it across
the board we see it with the january 6
folks we see it with people in the
military people and police you're not
allowed to even have
donated to kyle rittenhouse's legal
defense
fund anything that you do that runs
contrary to what they want you to do
is going to put you at risk heaven
forbid you work with the president
you help the president yeah they want to
get in there they want to see his
communications they want to see his
documents i mean look
go ahead no they've gone after people's
jobs they've already we've already seen
from the establishment
don't let anyone get a job if they
worked with the presidential
with trump's administration so that's
like the lowest level of it you're a
trump supporter
get out don't wear the maga hat you
believe you're crazy you're a white
supremacist
now it's it's that it elevates to
anybody who's ever worked the trump
administration you'll never be allowed
to work again
or at least in their system which is why
it's so important that we build our own
networks but then you see what happens
with big tech and the media
so i'm a little pessimistic now i mean
we had some we had some good stuff
you know like the falcon winter soldier
i was all excited i was like the ending
of that show is great
you know this guy takes the american
flag and beats antifa with it
but that's just the tv show that's not
justice where we watch what happens with
the chauvin trial
they they're walking these jurors
through riots with security with with
with
you know with and what what what did
andrew say they had uh
mp5s or something yeah i think so
whatever guns they were using
uh they were using very serious weapons
to protect the jurors
one of the jurors actually lived in the
city where riots were happening there's
no justice
and we're watching this across the
country now it's happening again then
you get a story where it's the former
previous president's lawyer is being
raided by the doj
as soon as merrick garland gets in
appointed by joe biden
there it is green light go after those
who opposed us you think merrick
garland's got a bone to pick
i would say so with giuliani just in
general right with the republicans in
general right
i think we are watching the the cult
take over
yeah it's been happening for some time
it's everywhere it's in everything it's
in every nook and cranny of every agency
every bureaucracy
every every bureaucracy cop chapter
every
every institution every everything and
it's like at some point
you we just have to accept it i still
even in this work that i do and the
conversations that i have and the
research and the people i talk to
i still am a little shocked each time
i still am a little saddened each time
i still feel like a bit of my optimism
and my
my idealization of america is still
there
and so each time this had just chipped
so like when
when am i going to become totally black
pill this is the question
and it hasn't happened yet where like
the next thing that happens happen and
i'm like oh yeah
totally unsurprised there's two big
issues the first
is that the the you know the the cult
the the establishment cronies have
attained such a level of power that they
can literally do this
when donald trump you know chance lock
her up at this rallies they're screaming
like oh heavens
oh we cannot be a country that threatens
to to to
send the legal system against our
political rivals what's that trump's out
of office
sign the legal system after our
political rivals indeed that's exactly
but the other thing is the unwillingness
of americans to stand up for
the principles of this country so before
before the show we were talking about
like local police departments and i'll
tell you i guarantee you
you will have a bunch of cops right now
who are going like man
i get it you know these guys are saying
how bad it's getting and i totally
recognize the corruption in office
we got to do something about it then his
boss walks in and he says
uh johnson go arrest jack murphy for
sedition he goes you got it boss hey
jack go to prison for the rest of your
life and you're like what
i'm doing what i'm told because i don't
care so long as regular people just go
along with whatever the insane garbage
is
it's not it's not gonna change well the
problem with the police department is
you've got people that go in who are
true believers who
might now become cynical and not want to
participate
then you got people that are doing it
because it pays better than their next
best alternatives
and it barely pays and it barely pays so
now you add
this extra pressure to it you're not
going to get the idealist
you're not gonna get the people with
better options you're gonna get people
with even worse options saying
this is my best choice to enter in this
position that basically everybody hates
no one wants a round
and you have to go do terrible dirty
work on people you're gonna get goons
it's like venezuela
these these the venezuelan soldiers are
like i get food if i do what you know
maduro wants
and if i don't i don't get any food
literally don't get it if i don't
see this this is the thing that the the
establishment cult like you know woke
left and corporate neoliberal people
understand way better than conservatives
it's that
there is no loyalty among the average
person to any of their fellow countrymen
they know that which means you can
literally have
fbi agents who are like man this is
freaking me out and they go
now go arrest him okay boss whatever
gleefully being like i swear an oath to
the constitution
is that a gun to prison with you that
that troubles me dude
it troubles me that you say and i agree
with
and then i ask why why does
your why do your citizens feel no
loyalty to their fellow citizens
if that's not the case then
the citizenry is too broad
i think uh man we're we're
a gluttonous lazy people that has for
too long
maybe maybe this past couple of
generations have had no real struggle
you know just sitting around enjoying
the
the uh fruits of the previous wars and
the labor of the previous generations
now we've got you know fat homeless
people that's like how prosperous this
country is so now they become lazy and
just like i don't want to sacrifice my
my comfort for you so you will get
right now like cops who swear an oath of
the constitution
and then violate the constitution every
single day and saying whatever well in
their mind their oath is to the
constitution but their oath is to the
guy who's giving them orders right in
their mind it's like the constitution
orders okay i do what they say yeah i'm
not a lawyer i don't i mean i'm just
projecting i mean i don't really know
it's true we had andrew uh on last night
yeah and he was talking about
that the chief police is a politician
once you get to that level of the law
enforcement you become a politician and
they basically are political
we want to think of it as a civil civil
movement but the police are basically
answering to the politicians and if the
politicians go in a political
direction the police but but it's it's
the individual officer who can say no
right right so i don't want to derail
too much we're talking about you know
giuliani and
and the point in which the federal
government now is arresting its rivals
so let's go back in time let's go back
in time to what 2017
i think it was when we started seeing
when was the berkeley the battle for
berkeley was that 2017
it was after the election yeah yeah milo
was there
and yeah so at this point you're seeing
these clashes and the proud boys show
up that was bike lock day wasn't it i
think that was 2017 yeah but then it
happened again for the next year or so
yeah
and over the next year i started talking
about i remember
i was talking to a bunch of dc
commentators and conservative
journalists
and i was like this is scary because the
escalation of this is civil war
and then you know immediately i get
pushed back from these conservative
you know dc folks who are like oh come
on
it's just a bunch of people fighting in
the street and i said listen
at what point does this escalate further
and further until it reaches the highest
level of government
no that's never going to happen the
security state is strong it won't allow
collapse blah blah blah
pretty sure when the doj seizes the cell
phone of the previous president's lawyer
you you're seeing the the breakdown
sorry it's
it's there you go i mean i know we've
had i know
we've had crazier with like nixon and
watergate and stuff or i shouldn't even
necessarily say crazier because maybe it
wasn't maybe it was just crazy and
maybe now when you combine the years of
street conflict the years of media
manipulation
the lies and the the foreign collusion
interference all the crazy whatever
with now that joe biden is in power he
brings in
garland mayor garland goes after the
trump administration i don't think we've
seen anything this crazy
since the civil war and it's just
getting started
so the united states has been abroad
as a foreign occupying force fighting
counter
insurgency battles against the
insurgents that are trying to
expel the government from their
occupation
that's exactly what they're going to do
here now they are a hammer
we are the nails and this is going to be
the war on terror 3.0 but it's really
the war on drugs it's really the war on
americans this is war on americans 1.0
and they're going to use the entire
apparatus that they've developed over
two decades now
of being an occupying force and
squashing dissent they're going to use
it here
in the united states and dude we
predicted this at you know at the end of
last year
and now it's happening and now tonight
is the night joe biden's going to go on
tv
he's going to call all the 400 people
they've arrested and january 6th is the
insurgents
responsible for the most egregious
attack on our democracy since the civil
war
they've already shown that they're
trying to filter out the the armed
forces
the police everyone else if you just had
any inclination to support trump or kyle
rittenhouse or anybody else
they're coming after all of us the d
trumpification is a real thing
why we can't let this happen again
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time